hi I'm Andy Griffith's I'm a National
Geographic photographer and author of
national Geographics new book simply
beautiful photographs I think the
elements that make a photograph
beautiful are a combination of the
classic elements of light of composition
and moment and then you can add to that
the elements of color of time and then
wonder I've been able to really dig
deeply into our archive and I find so
many pictures many of which have never
been published that really deserve to be
seen
I'm David Doubilet I'm an underwater
photographer of the three photographs of
mine there in this book my favorite is
the sea lions of South Australia there
are very endangered species and
extraordinarily friendly they're more
like golden retrievers it was a glorious
glorious 40 minutes with them I was
looking at light I was looking at the
way the light struck the green meadow of
grass I was looking at the way the light
blended off the sea lions fur underwater
and they came together and for one frame
one moment they made this picture I'm
Jody Cobb
well I quite like the photograph of the
woman sitting in the cafe and in
Florence Italy I was doing a story on
love and what it means in different
cultures around the world and I was
walking by a cafe and I was I was drawn
to the sort of the gesture of the leg
and the way that her white skirt draped
over her leg so I just snapped a few
pictures and then then when I saw that
the newspaper she was reading which was
actually a greeting card that was sent
to her said I love you on it it was just
sort of the bonus
it was the it was the the prize of that
photograph
my name is Michael Melford the shot in
the book from Maine I was in a
helicopter at sunrise and I had been
studying the weather watching the
weather for days and days actually went
to the place where there was some fog
and the Sun had come up and it was
hitting that fog and the trees were
casting a shadow towards me in the Fox
if you look at the picture I'm shooting
into the Sun my name is ceci Bromberg
I'm Danish and I work for National
Geographic as a photographer this garden
where the picture is taken is from
principal Tompkins garden and st.
Petersburg and here was this woman
sitting on a bench together with her
fairly young infant and and of course
she had no idea of how much of the of
the image I was including she didn't
know she was in the picture herself and
then she's just looking down into the
bassinet at the same time as I was
taking the image and that's of course
what really worked because of her
proudness and and motherly feelings
they're really coming through in the
image
my name is Jim Blair I walked over from
the hotel the big International Hotel in
Dhaka towards the bridge that overlooks
the mahogany River as I approached the
bridge
I could hear laughter down below and I
thought to myself you know something's
going on it's probably pretty good and I
peeked over the edge of the bridge and I
saw that the kids who take care of the
water buffaloes were had finished their
work and were swimming in the river and
having a good time and just then one of
the boys who was playing left off to the
back flip off the back of the water
buffalo and bam bam bam and the picture
was in a can this book simply beautiful
it's full of photographs that have
gestures in it there are decisive
moments in nature and decisive moments
on the pulse of the planet not just in
the way that humans behave toward each
other or juxtaposition 'el moments and
the book has these beautiful moments I
think anyone who's interested in
photography can become more and more
visually literate in the pursuit of
beautiful photographs it's kind of like
music in that someone who studies music
and practices music hears more when they
listen to a symphony likewise with
photography the more you pay attention
to it look at other people's photographs
photograph yourself get creative
understand your craft the more
successful images you're going to be
able to make
you